An equation is in slope-intercept form if we can write it as something like y
equals mx plus b, where m is the slope, which conveniently we already have for
our equation, and b is the y-coordinate of the y-intercept. Since we have slots
for x and y in our equations and we conveniently already have two points that we
know can belong in those two spots, we can use either of these points and plug
it into the slots for x and y. So we can start off with what we already know,
using the slope. I am going to use this point, 100,1200 and plug 100 in for x
and 1200 in for y. That's because we know that this point, or the coordinates of
this point, when substituted into the proper places in this equation, satisfy
this equation, or make it a true statement. That means we're allowed to use
them. I still don't know what the y coordinate of our y intercept is, so I would
really like to figure that out with the equation. So I want to get b by itself
on one side of the equation, and I end up with 700 equals b. Now you can take
this value and put it back in the equation we started with. That gives us a
final equation of y equals 5 x plus 700. So this is our answer. You could have
of course used the point 60, 1000 instead of 100,1200. And we can check to see
this is right by plugging in each of the coordinates for the 2 points to it. And
seeing if each side ends up equaling the other side.